ADAM MARTIN: OK.
So I'm going to start
out today's lecture
on the wrong foot
by quoting somebody
that you guys
probably don't know
and who was a New York Yankee.
So Yogi Berra, the famous
Yankee catcher once said,
"You can observe a
lot by watching," OK?
And that is very
appropriate for biology
because a lot of
things in biology
have been discovered simply
by watching for them in cells
or watching for them to
happen at the molecular level.
And so our ability
to visualize and see
what's going on inside cells
and at the molecular level
is really critical
for the process
of biological discovery.
So today I'm going to
tell you about tools,
both sort of older tools but
also kind of the cutting edge,
for how biologists
are really observing
what's going on in living
cells and in life in general.
OK.
So let me start by just having
you guys think a little bit.
What do you require of me to
see what I write on the board?
Yeah, Rachel.
AUDIENCE: Light.
ADAM MARTIN: What's that?
ADAM MARTIN: You need light.
And what does the
light help you to do?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: You need
it to see the board.
And so let's say
the light's on, OK?
Is that, can you read this?
No, what's the problem?
What's that?
Size, right?
So Natalie suggested size.
Right, so one
thing that you need
is some amount of
magnification, right?
But let's take another--
let's say I do magnify this.
What if I magnify it?
And I'm going to start writing
my notes on the board, right?
How is this?
Helpful?
Jeremy, what's wrong?
AUDIENCE: Differentiate
[INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah.
You have to be
able to distinguish
different objects, in this
case, these letters, right?
So in addition to
just magnifying it,
you also need the structures
to be far enough apart such
that you can distinguish them.
So you need what is
known as resolution.
OK.
This was resolution.
But this is resolution where
the letters are actually
resolved, OK?
So structures need to
be far enough apart
so that you can resolve them.
Now let's come back to
Rachel's point, right?
Why is it that we need light
to see what's on the board?
Right?
What if I draw without pressing?
Is that-- yeah, Orey.
AUDIENCE: You need contrast.
ADAM MARTIN: You need contrast.
Exactly, right?
The light sort of gives you
contrast between the chalk
and the black part of the board.
So you also need contrast.
And contrast is the ability to--
the structures need
to be differentiated
from the background, OK?
So structures need to be
different from background.
What else do you need
to read my writing?
Right?
What if I were just to--
everyone can read that?
What's wrong?
Carlos?
AUDIENCE: Needs to be
clear and legible--
ADAM MARTIN: What's that?
Yeah.
I need to have, like,
good handwriting, right?
So I like to think of this as
this is an aspect of sample
preservation, OK?
So there's a sample
preservation issue.
I can't butcher the
letters and the words.
OK.
So in the process of doing
all these other things, right,
magnifying your image,
resolving things in your image,
and generating contrast, you
can't destroy your sample such
that it's illegible,
basically, OK?
So in this case, structure must
be preserved while doing one
through three on this list.
OK.
So I'm going to start
with resolution.
We'll talk about, what are
the limits to resolving things
in biological specimens.
And in biology,
the one instrument
we use a lot is
a microscope, OK?
And a microscope is
basically a collection
of lenses that allow you to
do many of the things I just
drew on the board.
I'll point out a couple
sort of broad sort
of types of microscopy.
So the human eye up
here can resolve up
to about 100 to 200
microns, if you're
looking at something at reading
distant distance, right?
But cells are like way
smaller than that, right?
So we need some
sort of instrument
that allows us to
see things that
is lower than the resolution
limit of a human eye.
And so one way is to
use a light microscope
where you're using visible
light to observe your sample.
And many of the
images that you're
seeing that we're
showing you are
from visible light microscopes.
To see smaller things, type of
microscope that's often used
is an electron microscope.
And electron microscopy allows
us to observe structures
all the way down to the sub
nanometer level of resolution,
OK?
Now one limitation to
the electron microscope
is, you have to
kill the sample, OK?
So that can lead to
artifacts and problems.
And we'll discuss away at the
end where light microscopy is
being extended
down to the limits
that approximate that of
an electron microscope.
OK.
So what determines then, the
resolution of a microscope?
And so I'm going
to sort of define
a measurement of resolution
which I'll call the d-min,
or minimum distance.
And this will be the minimum
distance between two points
that can be resolved.
OK.
And what I showed you on
that past slide is basically
the limit on the right
here is the d-min
for these different types of
microscopy techniques, OK?
And what that means is, so
the minimum distance would be,
if your minimum distance is 200
nanometers, if two points are
greater than 200 nanometers
apart from each other,
then you can distinguish them
as two different objects.
However, if they are closer
than 200 nanometers together,
you wouldn't be able
to see that these
are two different objects.
They would be overlapping
each other, OK?
And typically, the d-min
for a light microscope
is around 200 nanometers, OK?
And the d-min results,
if we are to determine--
if I'm to tell you
what determines
this minimum distance, we have
to think about a microscope.
So here, I'm drawing
a specimen here.
I've just drawn my specimen.
It's on a slide or a cover slip.
Here's your specimen here.
And you might have
a light source
to generate the contrast.
And then there'd be some
sort of objective lens
underneath the slide
and the specimen.
So this would be
an objective lens.
Sorry about my sample
preservation here.
And so the light is going
to be hitting the sample.
And the objective lens
will be collecting
a cone of light that's going
into the lens here, OK?
And maybe I'll magnify this a
bit so you can see it better.
So I'm just going to magnify
this region over here.
So if this is my
specimen, I'm going
to draw the objective a
little farther away this time.
This is the objective.
And the objective
is able to capture
a range of different
angles of light
that come from the specimen, OK?
So it's collecting angles.
And I'll just define
here an angle theta,
which is like the 1/2 angle of
this whole cone of light, OK?
So what determines
the resolution limit
in this type of system is
first of all, the wavelength
of the light that's used.
So if you're using white light,
that might be from 400 to 800.
If you're exciting
GFP, you're going
to excite with a wavelength
that's 488 nanometers.
So it's usually around maybe
between 450 and 550 nanometers
for many different
fluorescent proteins.
OK.
So lambda here is the
wavelength of the excitation
of the light you're using.
And this is all then divided
by 2 times the NA, which is
a property of the subjective.
And what NA is, NA stands
for numerical aperture.
And what that is, is
basically the range of angles
that this objective
can collect, OK?
So it's N sine theta, where
theta is this angle here.
So you get the best
performance if the objective
can collect all of
the light that comes
from this side of the sample.
OK, and then N refers to the
refractive index of the media
that this light
is going through.
OK.
And so if you have
an objective and you
have your sample
in here and there's
a slide and a cover slip--
I'll extend this out--
you often have immersion oil.
There'd be some sort of
immersion media here.
And I don't know if you've
ever used a microscope that's
meant to be used
with immersion media
and you don't add
that immersion media.
But your image quality, if
you don't add that media,
is like really bad, right?
And that's because
you're affecting
the numerical aperture of
what this lens can collect.
And therefore, you degrade
your image quality, OK?
But basically, the more
light, the more angles of
light that you collect, the
higher the numerical aperture.
And therefore, the lower
this d-min is going to be.
And so the greater you'll be
able to resolve objects that
are near each other in space.
OK.
So the take home
message from all of this
is that you notice that
magnification is not
a part of this.
But the wavelength of the
light is really critical, OK?
So usually, this
minimum distance
ends up being the
wavelength of light
that you're using divided by 2.
And this usually ends up
being about 200 nanometers.
So that's the diffraction
limit of a light microscope,
as you see up there.
And this resolution is basically
limited by the diffraction
or behavior of light, OK?
So light microscopy is limited
by the diffraction of light.
And it was thought
for a long time
that no matter
what you do, you'd
never be able to break this
limit of about 200 nanometers.
But at the end of
the lecture, I'll
tell you about some very smart
people who figured out a way
to actually break this limit.
And we'll talk about how
they were able to do that.
Now I want to talk about
a few other limitations
of microscopy.
And I'm starting by showing
you this electron micrograph
of the endoplasmic reticulum.
And one important
consideration you have to make
is two dimensional versus
three dimensional structure.
So for electron
microscopy, you basically
cut the sample so you have
a very thin slice of it.
It's like slicing bread
except these slices are
on the order of 30 to
60 nanometers in height.
And then you pass an electron
beam through the sample
after it's stained in order
to visualize your specimen.
And one thing you
have to keep in mind
is that, you're looking
at a slice through this.
And it doesn't give you three
dimensional information, OK?
So if we were to think about
the endoplasmic reticulum,
you might have an
endoplasmic reticulum.
And if you take an optical
slice through this,
then you would see something
like this where you see each
of the stacks individually.
And so this might
make you to conclude
that the way that the
endoplasmic reticulum is
structured is it's kind of like
a stack of pancakes, where each
of these, you have
a lipid bilayer
surrounding a lumen of the ER.
So right, the lumen
would be inside
like this for each of these.
And they're just stacked
on top of each other.
And this is the textbook model
for endoplasmic reticulum
structure.
But it was actually, if you
don't consider this in 3D,
you might miss something.
And what was missed
was reported in 2013
in this paper, where
rather than just taking
a single slice, what they did
is they made lots of slices.
And they kept track
of where they are.
So they basically did a three
dimensional reconstruction
of the endoplasmic reticulum.
And by imaging this
other dimension,
they came to a very
different conclusion
about how the endoplasmic
reticulum is organized.
And instead of being
stacks of membranes
on top of each
other like pancakes,
instead, it's a helicoid.
So this is an ER from a
professional secretory cell,
like a salivary gland cell.
And you can see in 3D, you
get a very different picture
of the organization
of this organelle.
It's actually wrapped around and
spiraling membrane stacks, OK?
So their model is
that, basically
the endoplasmic reticulum
in some cell types
basically has a parking
garage like structure, OK?
So in this case,
in these cells, it
seems like the ER Is basically
a parking garage for ribosomes.
OK.
And you don't get
that information
unless you consider
the three dimensional
structure of the thing
that you're looking at.
So in addition to
electron microscopy,
there are techniques that
involve light microscopy that
involve optical sectioning.
And so normally, if you're
looking at fluorescence,
if you're doing
fluorescence microscopy,
you'd be exciting the
whole volume of your sample
and exciting all
of the fluorophores
such that fluorescence
from out of the focal plane
would be getting
into your image.
And that would give you a
much more hazy, unclear image.
But there are techniques
such as confocal fluorescence
microscopy that allow you to
exclude the out of focus light
such that you're basically
getting an optical section
through your sample.
And that can give you a much
cleaner and better resolved
image, OK?
Now I want to talk a little bit
about another dimension, which
is time.
And again, you're seeing
images in textbooks.
And usually, you're just
seeing a single image.
And whenever you
see a single image,
you have to think
about how things
might be changing in time in
order to understand the system.
So one example that I
like here is shown here,
where these are
different proteins that
are labeled in a yeast cell.
And you see that these
proteins form patches
at the edge of the yeast cell.
And some of these patches just
contain the green protein,
which is SLA1.
And other patches contain just
the red protein which is ABP1.
And there's another class of
patch which contains both, OK?
So how might you interpret
this fixed image over here?
What might be one model
you would conclude?
Well, what was
initially concluded
from this type of experiment is
you have three different types
of patches that are distinct
from each other in the cell
because they have different
molecular compositions, OK?
And that was what was
initially thought.
But it was wrong
because researchers
had to really consider the
aspect of time in this problem.
And I'm going to show
you a movie now over here
where you're going to
see this yeast cell.
And now you have these
different proteins
tagged with different
fluorescent proteins.
And we can watch them
in time as they progress
through a stereotypic cycle.
So what you're going
to notice in this movie
is that you see these
green patches appear.
And every single green patch
at some point is joined by red.
And then the green disappears
and the red stays around.
And then the thing
disassembles, OK?
So what was initially thought
to be three different structures
in the cell, eventually,
it was found out
that there was a
dynamic process where
this patch sort of
matured over time
and eventually
disappeared into the cell.
And what this process is, is
actually endocytosis in yeast.
And you're seeing
different proteins
getting recruited to
endocytic vesicles
as they bud from the plasma
membrane of this yeast.
OK.
So that's just my caution in
interpreting fixed images,
because you have
to think about how
they might be changing in time.
All right.
So now we have to
consider contrast.
And in bright field microscopy,
and bright field microscopy
basically involves white
light as your light source.
And so you'd have a microscope
that has a white light source.
You might have
your specimen here.
Here's your specimen.
Then you'd have some
sort of detector
at the end of your system.
And there would be some
objective lens in between,
which I'm going
to ignore for now.
And so, for bright
field microscopy,
you're taking a sample
and shining it with light.
The light that doesn't
go through your sample
will go right through
to the detector.
And that's your background.
But some of this light, the
light that's going and hitting
your sample, could be absorbed
or it could be refracted.
And it's the refraction
or absorption
of this light which generates
the contrast for bright field
microscopy.
So in bright field, native
structures in the cell
absorb or refract light.
And this is what
generates the contrast.
OK.
So the images shown up here are
bright field images of cells.
And in each of these
cases, there's no dye.
There's no fluorescent protein.
But you're able to see
the outline of the cell.
And you're able to see
even individual organelles
or structures
within the cell that
are interacting with the white
light and generating contrast,
OK?
So that's one way
to generate contrast
is just hope that whatever is
native in your cell generates
the contrast.
But there are also--
you can increase contrast
in specimens by adding dyes.
And if these dyes bind
to specific structures
like a membrane, then that
will increase your contrast.
So the electron microscopy
images that I showed you--
so for electron microscopy,
you generate contrast
by adding a dye that is an
electron-dense dye, which
will bend the electron beam.
And that's what allows you
to get an image from an EM.
So an EM contrast is from
an electron-dense dye
such as uranyl acetate or
some other type of dye.
Now, fluorescence microscopy, as
Professor Imperiali showed you,
involves taking a
fluorescent molecule
and attaching it to your
protein of interest.
So you're actually getting
protein-specific contrast,
which is very useful.
OK?
And the way a fluorescence
microscope works
is just shown up here where you
might have a light source that
has a range of wavelengths.
And you can use a
filter to select one.
In the case of GFP, it would
be blue light or 488 nanometer
light.
And that would then be
shined onto your specimen.
And then the light is
absorbed by fluorophores
in your specimen.
Some energy is lost, such
that the light that's
emitted from GFP is a longer
wavelength, in this case,
green.
And then you can
filter again to make
sure only the green light is
what goes to the detector.
So this is a very efficient
way of generating contrast
because you can use
filters to select
only the wavelength of
light that is emitted
from your fluorescent molecule.
OK.
Any questions about that and
about my very short version
of how fluorescence
microscopy works?
Yeah, Rachel?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
dichroic mirror?
ADAM MARTIN: The dichroic mirror
reflects certain wavelengths
that are below a
certain wavelength.
And will pass wavelengths
that are above a wavelength.
So it will basically reflect
the excitation light.
But it will pass the
emitted light, OK?
And so, there are
tons of these mirrors.
Some are not
dichroic, but they can
reflect four
different wavelengths
and pass all other wavelengths.
And so, this allows you to
image multiple fluorophores
at the same time, OK?
The specifics
aren't as important
as the general concept
of how this works.
OK.
Now I want to come back
to the resolution limit.
And I want to tell you
about how we can beat it.
So, beating.
We all like winning.
So beating the
diffraction limit.
And this is going to involve
a type of microscopy that's
really sort of been developed in
the past decade, which is known
as super resolution microscopy.
So super resolution microscopy.
And remember, I
mentioned for you
before that yes,
electron microscopy can
get you nanometer resolution.
But you have to kill the cell.
And also, it's hard to get
protein specific contrast,
right?
So that kind of sucks
because as biologists,
usually we're interested
in how things are
functioning to stay, to live.
So wouldn't it be great
if we could somehow
use light microscopy to get
down into this nanometer range
so that we can see how
individual proteins are
interacting with each
other and organized
at the nanometer level, OK?
And so in the past
decade, there's
really been a revolution
that's enabled
us to do light microscopy with
a resolution that gets down
to the 10 or even single
nanometer resolution.
And there's a number of
different super resolution
techniques.
I'm going to talk
about just one of them.
But both these
techniques basically
use the same concept, which
is that they enable whoever's
doing it to identify
single molecules
and define where those
molecules are very precisely.
And to turn fluorescent
molecules on and off
so that you can select
individual molecules such
that you can see them.
So these are two
different techniques.
They're conceptually
very similar.
I'm going to focus
on this one here.
But it's pretty much
similar to this one up here.
And I just want to point out
that one of our colleagues
here at MIT, Ibrahim Cisse
who's in the physics department,
his lab builds these super
resolution microscopes.
And they're using super
resolution microscopy
to study the collective
behaviors of proteins,
in his case, during the
function of gene expression.
OK, so this is research that's
actively being pursued at MIT.
So let's just do a
thought experiment again.
OK.
I'm drawing a single molecule or
what you would see in an image
if you were looking at
a single molecule GFP.
Great.
Where is GFP here?
Carmen?
AUDIENCE: It's right
there on the board.
ADAM MARTIN: It's right
there on the board, right?
Is it here?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
ADAM MARTIN: Who thinks
GFP is right here?
Who does not think
GFP is right there?
You have to be thinking
one or the other.
Yeah, Rachel.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: OK.
So what Rachel says is that
it's probably not right here.
It's probably in the middle
of this thing, right?
And so if you're seeing a
diffraction limited spot,
you're going to get some sort
of Gaussian of intensity,
which I didn't draw well here.
But it might be a little
bit brighter in the center
and drop off as you go
towards the edge, right?
So if I were to take
a image intensity
profile along the
line here, you'd
see something that kind of
looked like a Gaussian, OK?
And GFP, if there's a single
molecule that you're imaging,
should be right in the
center of this Gaussian, OK?
And so even though
we're not seeing a spot,
we're seeing a spot
that its width here
is diffraction limited.
So this width is 200 nanometers.
But if we can estimate
where the molecule is
in this region with
nanometer precision,
we could get a
very accurate view
of where this fluorescent
molecule is, OK?
So it relies on
certain assumptions.
The first assumption
is that you're
assuming we can see single
fluorescent molecules.
So that we visualize single
And that we can then estimate
with some amount of precision
the location of
the molecule based
on this diffraction limited
sort of image that we get.
So then we have to estimate the
location based on the image.
OK.
And then our resolution
is basically the error
in fitting this curve, OK?
So the error in
the fitted position
is equal to the standard
deviation of this Gaussian.
The standard deviation
divided by the square root
of the number of
photons that you
collected to get that image.
So the square root of
the number of photons.
OK.
And I just told you in the
beginning of the lecture
that this standard
deviation is limited
by the diffraction of light.
So the standard
deviation is going
to be around 200
nanometers, right?
But if you collect
a lot of photons,
you can accurately figure out
where the fluorescent molecule
is here if you know that
it's a single molecule.
OK?
So the number of photons
in a typical experiment
is going to be around
10 to the fourth, OK?
And so if 200 nanometers
by 10 to the fourth,
you're going to have
sub nanometer resolution
if you do the experiment right.
OK?
So you really need to see
fluorescent molecules, however,
in order to do this, OK?
And the real breakthrough
came with the realization
that you could combine
this type of fitting
to estimate the position
of single molecules
with a certain type
of fluorescent protein
where you can turn the protein
on and off stochastically, OK?
OK.
So we need one more
component which
is a photo-activatable
fluorescent protein,
in this case, the first one was
photo-activatable GFP PA-GFP.
And PA-GFP is a fluorescent
protein like GPF.
It's genetically encoded.
But when it matures,
it's not fluorescent.
It's in a dark state, OK?
So when it matures, it's dark.
It has a dark state.
And it starts out
in this dark state.
But you can turn it on.
And you can turn
it on with light.
So that's where the
photo activation
is, because you're
able to photo activate
this fluorescent molecule.
And you can photo activate
with sort of UV light or 405
nanometer light.
And so that's not normally
the excitation wavelength.
But if you shine your sample
with 405 nanometer light,
it will convert some
set of your molecules
into the now
fluorescent state, OK?
So this then causes
it to be fluorescent.
And now it's going
to be lighting up.
OK.
And I want to thank Professor
Cisse because he gave me
the next slide
which I think nicely
shows how this technique works.
So the way you can
get super resolution
is you can't be looking
at all your fluorophores
at once because they're
not far enough apart
and they'll all bleed
together so that you
get a bad image, right?
So this would be your
conventional diffraction
limited image where all
the fluorophores-- there's
about 20 fluorophores here.
And you can see, you can't
see individual fluorophores
and you can't see
what that says, OK?
But if you take a divide
and conquer approach
with this, if you have
a photo-activatable GFP,
you don't need to look
at them all at once.
You can just look at
three to start, OK?
So now if you only
activate a small subset
and you ensure that you're
activating it at a frequency
such that they're well
resolved from each other,
then you can distinguish
that there are
three single molecules here.
You can fit where they are.
And now you know where they
are with nanometer precision.
So you know where those are.
And then you want to
look at other molecules.
And so you have to
get rid of these.
And so what you would
do is to bleach them.
And bleaching is to use
light to basically damage
the fluorophores and get it
to no longer fluoresce, OK?
So this process is going to
involve an iterative photo
activation followed by
measuring and fitting the image
so that you can
basically determine
where each single
molecule is in your image.
And then ending with bleaching
to get rid of the fluorophores
you just turned on so that
everything is now dark again.
And then you repeat
this process iteratively
to collect all of the single
molecules that you can, OK?
So in this case, we just
got these three molecules.
We would then want
to bleach them
so that we're now going to
look at different fluorescent
molecules.
And we'll turn on
a certain number
of other fluorescent molecules.
Here you see four.
Here are two.
They're a little close
together, but you
can see that there are two.
Here are another two.
They're close together, but you
see two clear intensity peaks.
And so you can fit those four.
Now you have four more
molecules to make up your image.
You bleach them, excite
or activate five more.
Here are five
fluorescent molecules.
You can fit those.
Determine their positions.
And you just do this
iteratively over and over
again till you get as
many molecules as you can.
And at the end, you basically
add all these images together
to get the final super
resolution image, OK?
So this is an iterative process
where the photo activation
allows you to image
single molecules such
that you can see where they
are with nanometer precision.
And then you add
them all together
to get a super resolution image.
Here is an example
of this in practice.
And this is the
storm technique which
doesn't involve a photo
activatable fluorescent
protein, but involves
organic dyes blinking.
And the concept is
basically the same.
And here you see a
conventional image of an axon.
And it's labeled with
this beta-II spectrin.
And you see beta-II
spectrin is continuous.
And it's staining in this axon.
But if you look at the
super resolution image, what
you see is the beta
spectrin actually
has this repeated periodic
pattern along the axon.
And this is a
cytoskeletal element
that's basically
present in rings up
and down the axons of neurons.
And you can kind
of think of this
as like the axon is
a vacuum hose, where
you have these rigid
sort of rings that
are aligned all along the axon.
But because it's repeated and
you have intervening areas
without much cytoskeleton,
you can kind of
think of it as a
way for the axon
to be both rigid but also
flexible and maneuverable.
I just wanted to point out
that several super resolution
techniques were recognized
in the 2014 Nobel
Prize in chemistry.
Eric Betzig on the left
here developed the approach
using the photo activatable
GFP that I described to you.
And two others, Stefan
Hell and W.E. Moerner
were awarded it for other types
of super resolution technique.
If you get a chance, you should
go to the Nobel Prize website
and listen to Eric
Betzig's Nobel lecture.
He has a very interesting story.
And part of it
involved how he managed
to develop this technique.
And he actually developed it in
the living room of his friend.
So this is actually one of
the first super resolution
microscopes.
Here's the microscope
and here you see--
I love this chair.
But you see, you basically
have this microscope
in this guy's living room.
So if you want to hear
more about this story,
listen to his Nobel lecture.
He's a really funny
guy and you get
a sense of how
science really works
where you get this
unemployed guy like building
a microscope in his
friend's living room
and then wins a Nobel Prize.
And just one reminder to end
today, remember your news brief
is due this Friday,
November 30th.
If you need help on
selecting a topic,
please see a member
of our staff,
including Professor
Imperiali or myself.
And so, good luck with that.
Thank you.
I'm all set.